thank you very much okay so obviously
nothing that I do would be impossible it
would be possible without many of these
more much more famous brilliant other
people that I work with it and I would
like to put all of their names and I
tried but this is how it looks so so
really not much that I can do and I will
show a couple of names at the end so you
are talking about computational
processes in biology and basically
different processes that occur in the
sale so you have different kinds of
models and you have computational
complexity and algorithmic issues and
it's a fascinating area between biology
control theory discrete math and
computer science so the modeling problem
is that how do we incorporate the
biological data and for example
interaction data can be produced in the
form of a diagram that people have seen
mostly here like Lego diagraph and we
may want to pose questions about the
network about the dynamics of such a
network like how the behavior of a node
depends on other nodes and so forth and
dynamics can be continuous and discrete
depending on the state variables time
variables can be continuous discrete it
could be hybrid model it could be
deterministic verb distinct nature of
the model so for example the fun a very
broad level there are lots of a basic
research questions that are of interest
like for example which models are
experimentally falsifiable
so that they can be discarded how models
differ in terms of the computational
power and how feedback loops affect the
capabilities of different model which is
a very very interesting topic and what
degree of ilysm is possible in different
model and if you are a computer science
student not so much into biology but
little bit of a legend if you work in
distributed systems these are some of
the things that that might interest you
think of the cell system as a kind of
distributed system it has some nice
interesting properties like for many
cellular networks there is no global
clock but then somehow the processes
tend to synchronize how in distributed
of computing systems you also have this
kind of problem sometimes handle this
and special effect like localization so
for example for the world wide web we
have this geographical locations
effective communication and so forth and
so what is the corresponding rule for
localization Excel behavior what about
the communication delay is how do they
affect dynamics and so forth and so
forth so
so this talk I'll provide a brief
overview of research questions that my
groups in my collaborators have looked
at mostly high level overview and
technical details may be skipped because
of lack of time so the one thing that I
first wanted to talk about is reverse
engineering so basically it's something
that people in engineering Electrical
Engineering and other places always do
you are given some knowledge about the
process you want to you have access to
some kind of experiments in the case of
biology biological experiments and you
want to gain more knowledge about the
system so there are many very many ways
of doing it and you can even find
monographs or suffer papers the books on
that kind of stuff so the only thing
that the one method that I'm going to
mention is this modular response
analysis method and we are just going to
describe the method and followed by what
is the computational question there and
some kind of biological validation so
what you have is the differential
equation model so you have a set of
state variables and they evolve based on
some differential equation of time and
there are two kinds there are there is a
there are some parameters P 1 2 pn they
can be in effect controlled and they can
be manipulated and let this condition is
just a steady state condition in the
steady state condition assume that the
value is 0 normal de is it shifted
circuits 0
so the setting for the modular response
method is that we do not know the nature
of the function f but there is some
prior information about this kind of
knew about this nature is possible that
there are some parameters that do not
affect certain variables in other words
the partial derivative is 0 or not 0 so
not the actual value but whether it's
just a 0 or not that's what is available
not for every possible fi and PG but for
some of them ok so the experimental
protocol is this very simple you part
are one parameter say PK so when you
part up the state vectors the
concentration of proteins or activity
levels of gene expressions are changed
so you just let the system settle to a
steady state and you measure the the
state variables and then you can compute
the sensitivity which is the derivative
which you can approximate over a small
range by the difference equation so so
that's a straightforward is that so the
goal is that we want to obtain some
information about the sign of these so
we cannot hope to measure the actual
nature of these value or the rate but
what we want to show know is that
whether one state vector has a positive
or negative effect on another state
vector ok now that kind of thing we want
to know if at all possible from those
experiments
so in a nutshell if you do after some
combinatorics and linear algebra you can
quantify the additional amount of
information that you need okay the
amount of perturbations that the number
of perturbations that you approximately
need of information theoretically to
have the knowledge about this kind of
the knowledge of how each state variable
affects another state variable but if
you assume that you have sufficient
information or say close to sufficient
information then how do you determine
actual minimum number of perturbation
experiments that will give rise to the
inferences that you are looking for so
now if this becomes an algorithmic
question there's some kind of
optimization question and I said I'm not
going to discuss into too much of
details for this so this is a very high
level overview but after some effort you
can see the designing minimal set of
experiments correspond to some kind of
set multi cover problem so I'm not going
to describe the setting I'll take of a
problem or any such thing so but this is
basically the overview of the idea so
this is the modular response method of
our differential equation you have the
linear algebraic formulation then you go
through a community well formulation
where state multi cover comes into
picture and then you have some kind of
algorithm to select the perturbation
experient which is going to be a
randomized algorithm and then you select
the appropriate perturbation experiments
and then you do the experiments after
that and from there you can get the
corresponding conclusions about the
network that you're looking for and
there is also a feedback loop if you
don't like it that you think that
something in the network is wrong then
maybe some perturbation was done wrongly
or you need additional perturbation go
back and forth and with the biologists
until you are satisfied so this is the
overview of the of the system and
obviously I haven't
I discussed technical details of any of
this but there is an experimental
analysis so basically they are looking
at the map kinase pathway and these are
the three proteins and there are two
receptors and there are two NGA for EGF
these are the external stimuli so you
can control this this external stimuli
are this parameters P in the inner model
so you can actually control the stimuli
and thereby you can change the state
vector to another steady state vector
starting from a steady state vector so
the MRI method was applied with respect
to these two stimuli and these other
proteins and other molecules as nodes to
figure out the network and it was done
successfully it's actually a very small
network I don't know five nodes or four
nodes six nodes something like that so
there is no need to use a computer you
can actually do all the perturbation
right down it by hand and then you can
figure out so this is like a proof of
concept but it shows that it's possible
for the other yes yes sure invited it it
was actually in 2013 lished by Dennis t3
with something like 50 components try to
apply your method yep I like I kind of
left this topic so i am not working on
it anymore yeah i know there is some
work decent work are in fact that is
another work by barabasi
controversial works let's not talk about
it yes yeah I'll ask me later if you
want so the next thing that you want to
talk about is decomposing a biological
network into monotone systems so this
was a fun work to do again we have this
differential equation model the state
variables are evolving based on some
differential equation and for simplicity
or your mate input and outputs but it's
easy to incorporate them if you look at
the paper you will see that without
input output of course no system makes
any sense what's there
so monotone systems are a simpler
behaved subsystem like the dynamics is
very nice behaves for example
pathological behavior cows ruled out and
in many sense even though they may have
large dimension in many sense their
dynamics behaves similar to similar to
one dimensional system there are no
stable oscillatory behavior for example
so monotonicity is related to positive
and negative feedback loops and studying
of feedback loops is of course a very
well-known topic starting with this word
work of Mahad and Jacob so the important
thing to note is that interconnection of
a monotone system may or may not be
monotone in some sense positive feedback
preserves it but if you have negative
feedback destroys it
so the more advantage of studying
monotone system is that you can
characterize the behavior of an entire
system based only a small amount of
quantitative data and there is no need
to know the precise form of dynamics of
parameters such as kinetic constants in
the differential equation to infer many
things about the dynamics of the middle
so so far so good so the question so the
question that that we now need to
address is that our biological systems
monotone in dynamics and if not how
close are they so we again have the have
the differential equation model and from
the differential equation model you can
get something called The Associated
Stein graph so for every variable there
is a node and if the corresponding value
of the derivative is positive or
negative overall X then you get an
activation age or inhibition age
otherwise you don't get an H because the
behavior is not well defined
so and then who each way is okay and we
also define a notion of sign consistency
of the graph so to note the sign
consistency of the graph think of the
activation ajaces plus think of the
inhibition ages is minus and think of
the total sign of a path as the product
of these so plus x minus x plus whatever
sign you get so sign consistent graph
means every path between two nodes of
seven parity so this is not sign
consistent for example if you take the
path 12 for it is negative if you take
the path 1 2 3 4 it is plus minus and
plus or sorry 1 2 3 4 ply is minus minus
and plus so if you multiply you get plus
so you have two paths one with positive
and one is negative sign so this is not
a sign consistent graph whereas on the
left side the graph is sign consistent
so that's very easy coming at oriole
definition but what has this to do with
monotonicity so what can one can show is
that consistent graphs if you take the
differential equation model build the
corresponding associated sine graph and
if you look at the consistency of the
graph then you can say the graph is
consistent the corresponding dynamics is
monotone so it's not not both ways but
one way so it's also easy to check that
if a graph is consistent you can just
very simple modification of lloyd
partial type shortest path but what if
the graph is not consistent say almost
consistent so then the problem becomes
how many ages do we need to delete to
make the graph consistent so this is the
combinatorial problem so intuitively
it's like whatever edges you can take
out the remaining graph is consistent
and you can write the entire system as a
consistent network followed by Lucy's
negative feedback so that's how you can
express them to assistant
we are you haven't gone into details of
that to be consistent volume ii to take
care of his maybe not all but at least
you shouldn't have cycles with negative
sign yes so there is very easy no no no
no we will see the next slide we will
see it's not as difficult as feedback
back to easier
so these so actually what you get is an
undirected leveling problem so you have
to level the vertices such that if you
take the level of two vertex at them or
you'll owe to you get exactly the level
of the edge when the levels are 0 and 1
and whenever you do addition you have to
do módulo to as simple as that so it's
actually really simpler than the
feedback model because modulo 2 is easy
it's a similar to max cut in some sense
so you can define the degree of
non-attorney city as the maximum number
of consistent edges divided by the total
number of edges so that if the entire
graph is consistent it's one you have to
remove most of their yes it is close to
zero and otherwise it's between zero and
one so there is a statistical mechanics
interpretation the icing spin class
model if you consider this positive and
negative edges then maximizing a of the
number of consistent edges is same as
minimizing the free energy without any
external magnetic field so this is the
algorithm for you LP I'm not going to go
into details you have a semi definite
program you then solve it you have a
random hyperplane but all the only thing
that I want to emphasize this can be
easily implement it's not a utopian
algorithm it can be implemented using
matlab and you have we have the mat lab
coats you can you can download it so
tell you that you can probably also
implement it with I MP and solve it to
optimum oh yeah probably but then you
need a package friability it depends on
the size of the network of course if it
is Tula because we will show and RG
network so it can be proved that you get
almost 90 person so I LP or not it
really doesn't make much of a difference
and that's the performance guarantee due
to semi definite programming so we took
this network which is the fruit fly
Drosophila Network the signal
transduction network model which was
published by which was published in
Nature 2000 and this is a one cell level
and the neighboring cells are connected
using those links and it has 20 edges
and 13 notes our algorithm produced 17
consistent age and that's actually
optimal you can prove that for this
particular Network 17 is the number so
only three edges you can remove one you
can make the system sites it's the
monotone system with only three edges of
negative feedback loop you can write it
so this is just one sale of course if
the real network is not one cell so you
can take many cell network you can make
it into an one-dimensional array by
connection through those external the
two external outputs and so our
algorithm so if you have a row of
castles algorithm produces 17k
consistent age and you can show that
that's actually exactly optimal you
cannot do better so the other thing that
we did was that you looked at the EGF a
signaling network so this is the this
dish network was published by eau de at
all he provided 330 molecules and 211
chemical reactions so it's built from
many sources and you can get it in the
SB ml format so what you do is notes
a330 molecules and each reaction
classifies the molecules reactants
products and enzymes and so basically
these are the edges 0 1 and undefined
end means that there is a conflict and
both of them happens fortunately only
seven edges are undefined so if you
ignore them or somehow incorporate them
in another way you don't really lose
much so graph has 852 age only 211
reactions so it's actually dense it has
been sub graph so this is how you saw
you ran the randomized algorithm and
found 633 consistent edge out of the 852
which is not which is not very large so
the lots of edges have to be deleted to
make it 100 so it's not really very
close to monitor at least with respect
to this algorithm the question is that
maybe the 633 is low because the
algorithm was dead or maybe it can be
made even more better right so what we
can say is that because of the
performance of the algorithm with very
high probability the actual number of
consistent edges will be 728 so how
close to 7 28 we can get well so
so we finally so we finally are left out
with 137 so if you subtract 137 48 52
that would be that would be how much 700
something so those many consistent edges
are there and they're pretty close to
optimal so if you use another hybrid
algorithm that you design not just the
SDP but is DP with some other algorithm
then you can actually get close to
optimal so with that we by the way I did
and for some reason this this algorithm
generated what is it lots of quite a few
papers in the computer science community
because apparently people could apply
this particular community real problem
to some financial markets and some other
places and apparently there you will get
the same kind of coming at real problem
somehow which I was not aware of so the
last part would be in signal
transduction network so we talk about
three things topological synthesis
minimization and topological degeneracy
and NC so I'll just focus on the very
last part and kind of skip over the
first two because we don't have time so
overall goal is that you have direct
interaction you have double causal
interaction additional information then
you need a fast method software and you
want to build a network that's minimal
complexity and biologically very very
relevant so there are various kinds of
experimental evidence biochemical
pharmacological genetic evidence for
differential stimulus so some of these
evidences correspond to a chain of
chemical reaction some of these
evidences correspond to direct one-step
chemical reaction so but sometimes we
don't know whether it's a chain or just
one step sometimes you know sometimes
you know for certain certainty so so
direct
interaction is like this and double
causal chain type interaction is that
these two are affecting through some
strange intermediate node that you don't
know another mode so critical h means
that an edge that you are hundred
percent sure that that is the right age
there is no way it should be deleted
from the network so there is some
notation that you get and then you have
two steps for network synthesis money
see you do not collapse and one is by
nourished transition so this is
polynomial time easy and these NP hard
and this needs the heuristic and so few
not collapse and so binary so this is
basically graphically what it shows that
if you have a H&M same penalty as the
edge then you just remove that age so
something like that intuitively and you
cannot remove a critical edge never so
this is the overall goal you synthesized
you have interaction optimized
synthesized double kaushal interaction
and then you optimize interact with
biologists so biological validation we
took this plant signal transduction
network this is a network this isn't at
work for the stomatal closure of ara vdf
siciliana and manually curated and the
so the network was was curated and
constructed manually so we did we wrote
a software for this and construct a
network so this is actually the manual
curation this is our curation and our
curation takes just one or two seconds
and basically it's a very similar kind
of network whatever is the minor
discrepancies is not it is not
unjustified
oh yes it's it's the previous one it's
what is it over it oh it's not here it's
here i forgot i deleted the slice but
it's a slide it's basically it has like
hundred notes and some may be between
below 200 ages this particular network
that is from the literature here that
takes few years just from those data so
so these are a list of experimentally
observable double causal relations so
you need this data and feel the data so
they have the interaction data some of
the interaction or direct one step some
they don't know it can be over a chain
or biochemical reaction and so forth and
so forth but the data is there be except
that we had to correct a little bit some
of the data based on our knowledge but
our workers may not we who you are
parasites in previous who said you are
parasites yeah
so so the two are highly similar and
then you want to look you can download a
software just run click I don't maintain
any server and for Linux when you can
just ask for the source code but it will
there will be no graphics interface and
we also looked at another application of
the software you wanted to synthesize a
cell survival cells cell death in large
granular lymphocyte you come here so so
what we did was that we we basically
found there are two pathways that are
important for the cell survival said
listener to work and want to concentrate
on pathways and try to minimize the
network such that we can focus on those
pathways and that can be done using a
software so in some sense it was
simplifying the network getting rid of
unwanted nodes and edges while focusing
on those specific fast fast ligand
pathways which are important for the for
this disease so you can see for the
result in this direction and then the
last thing that I want to talk about is
measuring degeneracy and G undhan see if
you are an electronics or electrical
engineer then you know these concepts
very well information theory also in
information theory also you know these
concepts and it's also known that
biological networks do not have lowest
possible degeneracy for example
connectivities of neurons they have a
very high level of redundancy so for
example I use this code although many
similar examples exist in all fields of
levels of biology a specific notion of
degeneracy has to be firmly incorporated
herein the biological thinking largely
because of lack of a formal theoretical
framework and the other thing is also
that there is a lack of effective
algorithmic procedure so so you can
define this based on the information
theoretic measure and you can go through
mutual information of systems and define
it the problem is that
the number of combination that you need
to do to evaluate this is you can easily
see if n is 50 you have to go to 10
power 15 combinations so what you do is
that so you can use the binary
transitive reduction to define and then
you can calculate the intensity and
p-values for various networks and you
can have some conclusion based on there
in NC value so illogical networks like
one rear our conclusion is their
topological redundancy of metabolic
network the C elegans metabolic network
is due to currency metabolites and so
forth so this is a slide that I pick the
puter I put there and I just out of my
head is that whether you can apply
spectral methods inferred for studying
biological systems biological networks
or even phylogenetic networks like if
you take the laplacian of the graph and
eigenvectors and what happens then so
some related publications which you
don't have to read because it's
impossible to read and this is a book
that you wrote a shameless advertisement
and but this is something that that is
very very important because without
money we cannot do in research and
finally these are the pictures of some
collaborators obviously and whatever
picture I could grab as you can see
easily that I look much better than all
of these people so with that any
questions that you have to ask